now even in the
dark you'll
[Music]
find Christian
I will build my house where
St your
faithfulness will
prove you are
[Music]
stay
you by the words you spoke all the
star I call out by name each night
your what
[Music]
Hal
Christian
[Music]
oh
hello hi
happy to see you
[Music]
here close
close few away
[Music]
[Applause]
woohoo
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
the table or if you would like to make
your home we'd love to see you here um
you can scan the QR code to sign up for
that and now Anna Anna is gonna come
talk to us about
suama yeah okay hey guys um so this is a
little odd for me because I am used to
being in front of all of your sweet
kiddos um and I absolutely love them but
we have some really exciting news for
y'all so first off we have started our
very own table kids Instagram account so
I know I know it's exciting isn't it um
so we are going to be posting all sorts
of stuff on this page uh we're going to
be posting our events that we're having
for the kiddos volunteer options and
just pictures of what all we're doing um
if you would like like to follow that
page that would be amazing our handle is
the Texas so TX kids table and the TX is
capitalized okay so it's the capital T
capital x and then all lowercase kids
table uh we will be posting information
on the events here so we really do
encourage parents to follow us we
encourage anyone who's at our church to
follow us so you can kind of see how to
get plugged in okay um second of all it
is officially summertime kids are we
excited or what woo I know okay so that
means it is time for summer Rama and we
cannot wait okay the kids are excited
I'm excited the other adults on our
ministry team are excited we cannot wait
this year's theme is passing the torch
and we are doing it Olympic style so
grab your sweatbands grab your fanny
packs grab your 80s sweatsuits and come
down and have some fun with us at
summerama it's going to be June 21st and
22nd and we are always always always
looking for volunteers so if you look at
the screen above there's going to be a
QR code that will take you to a
volunteer signups page and registration
for your kiddos okay so sign your kiddos
up and also sign up to volunteer we have
a lot of fun um and the kids make it
amazing lastly to kick off summer this
year we are going to be doing popsicles
in the park it is going to be June 7th
from 10 to 12 okay it's right here on
the board it's at Waters Edge Park okay
and it is going to be so so much fun
we're going to do popsicles uh we're
going to have some games to play and
we're just going to love on your kiddos
and have a really great start to our
summer um be looking at our Instagram
because we're going to have more posted
there about the Popsicles in the park
[Music]
thank you
Anna so uh now we're going to exit this
man-made Kingdom of noise and hurry and
productivity and we enter the kingdom of
Silence Stillness and simplicity a
Sacred Space a space for prayer worship
and adoration a space to behold Christ
revelation of God and heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you and to M your heart
may we all come
home all right will you guys stand with
us we want to celebrate the good works
that God has done in each one of our
Lives tonight so you follow Jesse on
this one sing it
out I was
[Music]
buried I was
bued
beneath my
shame who can
carry that
kind of
way it was my
till I met
you and I was
breathing but
not
[Music]
alive all my failures I
Tred to
[Music]
hide it was
my still I been
you you called my
name and I ran out of that
[Music]
grave out of the
darkness into your glorious
name you called my
name and I out of that
grave out of the
darkness your glorious
[Music]
day now your
mercy has
save my soul
tell your
freom is
all I
know the old made
new Jesus when I met
you you called my
name and I ran out of that
gra out of the dark
Darkness into your glorious
day you call my
name I out of that
gra out of the
darkness into your glorious day
[Applause]
[Music]
I needed
rescue I needed resue my sin was heavy
but chains break at the weight of your
glory I needed
sh I was in nor now you call me a czen
in
the when I was broken you are my healing
now your love is the air that I'm
breathing I have the future My Eyes Are
Open CU When you call my
name I ran out of that
grave out of the
darkness into to your
[Music]
[Applause]
glory you call my
name and
[Music]
our of the
darkness into your glorious day
all right o is leading the way over here
so you guys can follow him over to the
doors kids um your teachers will meet
you at the doors and then they will lead
you over to your
classrooms thank you guys Brock and
Amanda all you other kids ministry
workers we're so grateful for you guys
[Music]
and now we're going to transition into
the prayers of the people um I know some
of you are with us for the first time so
this is um a tradition that has been
passed down throughout Christian history
that we um partake in each week and it's
really just a portion of our service
where we want to acknowledge the things
that we're carrying into this space um
the people that are on your heart or the
situations um that you are carrying that
might be heavy tonight and offer those
up um as a community and name them
believe that God is here with us um and
he wants to shoulder those with us and
we want to shoulder them with each other
so we're going to um read through this
prayer and you can follow along on the
screen um and read the parts in red
aloud together and then there will be
space for you to share your requests um
aloud and then we'll finish out the
prayer together all
right Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in in them we pray to you for
the Good Earth that you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it we pray to you for the old and the
sick for the Widow and orphan for the
injured and suffering we pray to you for
the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulner able the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
in
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
my mother's
womb in my mother's
wom you form me with your hand known in
Love by
you before I took a breath when I doubt
it Lord remind me I'm wonderfully made
you're in AR and a I'm the can and
you make all
things work
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things work
together for your
glory and for your name
[Music]
there's a healing
light there's a healing
light just beyond the L though I walked
through
far I see
clearly nothing has been wasted no
failure or mistake you're an artist and
a on the canas and
the you make all
things work
[Applause]
together for my
future and for my good you make all
things put together
For Your
Glory and for your
[Music]
name when
I when I doubt it Lord remind me I'm
wonderfully made you're an artist and a
part
I'm the canas and the clay and I know
nothing has been Wast no fa your all
mistake you're an artist and a Potter
I'm the canas and the glay and when I
doubt it Lord remind me I'm wonderfully
made you're an arst and a I'm the canvas
and the
no nothing has been wasted don't feel
your all mistake you're an
[Music]
arst oh you're not with you're not
finished with me you're not finished
with
me you're not finished with me you're
not finished with me you're not finished
with
me you're not finished with
me you're not finished
with not fin with me
[Music]
so about two years ago um I was at a
dead end in life like all of life like
life itself dead end um and I really did
feel like there was nothing left there
was no future there was no plan there
was nothing that whatever happened
whatever my life looked like it just
ended up at this dead end and it was a
sad ending and it just felt like there
was no continuation for a while and then
I received a lot of help from this
community from my folks from my siblings
from friends and um worked on myself and
now I'm here to tell you that God's not
finished with you trust me because I
felt that I really did I was like and
y'all y'all have probably already all
been there where you're like okay this
is well okay so what happens next what's
going to happen how's God going to fix
this what's how how are we going to
break through this because this looks
literally impossible and I don't see any
hope I don't see anything I felt all of
those things I still do at times but I'm
here to tell you that you need to sing
these words over yourself even if you
don't believe them especially you're not
finished with me yet which we're going
to go into I want you to sing those
words even if you don't believe it it's
okay just sing it over yourself because
he's not finished with you he wasn't
finished with me I got a tattoo about it
here on my arm your story is not over
you have so much more and the best is
yet to come it is true there is hope on
the horizon it might take a few years
but if you just hold on to your
community and you listen to God and then
you listen to your intuition and you
allow yourself to receive help from
people you will get there so when we
sing this now which we're going to go
into now finally is you're not finished
with me yet I want to hear y'all sing it
as we're going into it right in a
second I don't want to sing it alone
okay you're not finished with me
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me no you're not finished
with me you're not finished with me
you're not finished with me you're not
finished with me no you're not finished
with me you're not finished with me
you're not finished with me yet you're
not finished with me you're not finished
with me yet you're not finished with
me you're not finished with me yet
you're not finished with me now you're
not finished with
me amen
[Music]
God thank you that you continue to do a
good work in us that you've made room
for us
here that your love is
[Music]
spacious come all proud come all
greedy come all
come all
shame come all wealthy come
receive to the table come
today come all
broken come all
needy come all poor and come all
slaves all rulers come be seated
come all Sinners Come All Saints come to
the
[Music]
table from near and
far come from the
Shadows come out of the
dark there's room at the table
[Music]
we save you a
SE come to the
bqu come join in the
[Music]
Fe every race and every
nation come on re come
on from the
fres come to Jes Jesus to a table full
of
grace to the
table come and stay come to the
[Music]
table come eat
and there's no inner
cirle come with the King
recline at the
table come let down your
God you're never
[Music]
stranger just come as you are
come
meold come be
loved come
[Music]
accepted come now come
come be
all come
be come
accepted come now
come come
be come be
love come
[Applause]
[Music]
accepted come now
come prepared is a
table we're ready to
Fe the party is
waiting there's more still the
feet the Harvest is
ready go fill every
seed go live out the
nation as a kingdom of
PR go live out the
Miss there a kingdom of PRI
[Applause]
[Music]
God would we live out what you've called
us
to your way of
love a self-sacrificing
[Music]
love that's not grasping for
control but a love of
Grace of
forgiveness of wholeness
[Music]
God call us into your love and let us
live there let us share it in our world
in our homes at our
work God would it Infuse our
[Music]
lives would we be your
people your
children fully known and fully loved
in Jesus name
[Music]
amen you guys can turn to the people
around you and say hello and then we're
gonna have a little moment here for our
seniors
all
right the balloons are in place we're
ready to
go we're marking this moment um guys we
wanted to take some time as a community
to acknowledge some high school senior
graduates among us tonight in our
community yes there are actually Four
total seniors uh represented in our
community Kaylee Adams Riley Brock Hank
cumle and Eden
McDonald and um yes um and before I call
them up we all are probably very aware
that graduating high school is not a
solo effort there's a lot of family and
parental and communal support that goes
into that so if you are a parent of a
high school graduate and you could just
stand we want to applaud you right now
so if your student graduated high school
we honor
you y'all are so rebellious I said to
stand
up they're looking at me like no I will
not
stand what a rebellious group okay the
seniors are actually much more obedient
than
y'all so um if the two of our seniors um
are actually gone on senior trips right
now and not with us tonight Riley Brock
and Kaylee Adams but we would like to
focus the next few minutes on the two
seniors who are with us tonight which is
Hank humble and Eden McDonald so if you
guys could join me up here and our youth
team come on up with them um we want to
take a minute and talk about you guys
you can give them a round of applause
[Applause]
we're
yeah the old
fogies this is Eden McDonald and uh Hank
humble and um we Abby and Michael myself
and Marissa martinz who's out of town
right now and couldn't be here actually
tried to change her flight to get back
in time for this and wasn't able to
um but um the four of us have been
meeting with these guys on Sunday nights
in our teen Meetup and Hank and Eden are
part of what I like to call the faithful
five we we don't have a big youth
program here at the table but we do have
five very faithful students who meet
weekly um and Hank and Eden are two of
those students who have been um just a
very huge core part of who we are and
you guys have seen them up here on um
some of our youth nights where we um do
youth services but um we wanted to say a
few words about you guys that were given
to us by your peers so I'm gonna hand
this off to Michael
first is his thing on okay Anonymous
says Hank always checks in on me and I
appreciate how he shares his thoughts
another says I'm excited to see what's
next in his life Hank is authentic and
creative and he can make any anyone
laugh this one's from Marissa she says
Hank you're a truly remarkable young man
in so many ways wise and mature for for
far beyond your years you never cease to
amaze me with your thoughtful
intelligent insights and genuine care
for others your Gentle Spirit and tender
loving heart are such beautiful
attributes that I admire so much and I
consider it a tremendous privilege to
Bear witness to you Hank this one's for
me I want to take time to praise both
your attention and your your intention
you have a gift with letting people feel
seen and heard that I know will bless
those around you for as long as you
[Applause]
live okay so I have a few as well about
Eden um first off inclusive to everyone
in the youth group I'm thankful for all
the laughs and the memories authentic
compassionate and able to connect with
anyone always contributes his best
Marissa also sent in a few notes Here It
has been my greatest honor to watch you
grow into your heart and personality
these past couple of years you're an
incredible example of thoughtfulness
love and resilience and you're a
beautiful role model for me through your
boisterous exuberance you have an
uncanny way of quietly observing others
and so beautifully loving them in ways
uniquely suited to each um Eden has
brought an absolute light to our youth
group his intelligence and love extends
to not only everyone in our group but
this entire church
Community
amen so you want to just quickly tell
through your
tears tell us what your plans are from
here
Hank um I've been attending Colin
College the last few years and I'm about
to wrap up an associates degree in
animation and game art this next either
December or early spring 2025 so I'm
excited to finish that
up um I am going to U this fall um and I
am going to study psychology there and I
hope to get my masters in
counseling so fitting for both of
you um we have gifts here and um that
for you guys that are youth team these
are um some Bibles that we have gone
through ourselves and highlighted our
favorite scriptures written our names
beside them and hope that they can serve
as kind of a light on your path and have
that Personal Touch Of Us guiding you as
you go and we want you to stick around
as much as possible after you graduate
actually Hank's graduating a little bit
early because he's amazing like that and
so he'll hopefully still be hanging
around in youth um for a while with us
as much as he's able um and then of
course Eden will be off at College some
so I'm sure we won't get to see you as
much but we hope to see you still
regularly as much as possible you're not
too far away um but we did want to pray
a blessing over you guys and send you
off um just into this next season of
your lives even if it's not to a far off
location um but it is a new season so um
Abby and Michael if y'all will help me
lay hands on them and um you guys feel
free to extend your hands um I'm going
to start by reading a scripture from
First
Corinthians
um and it
says every time I think of you and I
think of you often I thank God for your
lives of free and open access to God
given by Jesus there's no end to what
has happened inside of you it's beyond
speech Beyond knowledge the evidence of
Christ has been clearly verified in your
lives
and my prayer for you guys is
that
um you would go from this place knowing
that you are loved and that you are
blessed Abby Michael and myself have
borne witness to the work of God in both
of your lives we celebrate who you are
we affirm the fruit of the spirit in
your speech and your actions we send you
with blessings and assurance that you
are never alone
and that God will always be enough for
you and we pray for you that you would
know how deep how wide how long is the
love of Christ in Christ's name we pray
[Applause]
amen all right
yeah let's move the
balloons that'd be really weird someone
like tuning in online just like what is
up why are they doing that with that
Pastor um well welcome everyone and uh
Eden and Hank love y'all lots so so
proud of you and this this transition
you're in um and uh I want to welcome
all of you into this space thank you for
joining us and what a special a special
day just really really um yeah unique
and powerful and wonderful to be
together and as always that includes
those join us online love y'all lots and
um anyone here tonight who is new um I
know it can just take a lot of courage
to come through those doors into a new
space a new community so um thank you
thank you for for doing that so we are
um in the midst or I should say really
begin
um a new series tonight uh titled holy
shift been looking forward to saying
that all
week holy shift a 21st century Faith so
um in short we're going to be kind of
looking at these um like cultural kind
of some of them value some of them more
like practices uh that are it's just
they're ubiquitous like they're just
everywhere in our life and culture um
but but often I don't know they it's
amazing how culture just kind of slips
into us and we just engage things we
don't really think about them much
necessarily uh because we're too close
you know just like you go to a different
culture and you can see it with fresh
eyes you can be like whoa that's really
interesting or why do you do it that way
you know but the culture you're in
you're just in it you know it's like a
fish in water like what's water never
heard of it right it's just it just
surrounds you um so that's what we're
going to be doing is looking at uh some
of these kind of values and practices
that are in the culture
that I think uh it's not necess that
they're each like inherently sinful or
something it's more like we need to do
some reflection on some of these and
make some shifts right from that maybe
value um either put a Twist on it or
change it in some way engage in a
different way um and so we'll be talking
about some spiritual values and
practices and uh things like that that
we can shift into so with that in mind
uh the title of my message tonight uh is
um entertainment holy shift
entertainment and uh of course every
like every culture you know has had its
forms of entertainment so again it's not
to say being entertained you know how
dare you that's the worst you know like
every culture that I mean I can imagine
uh even the most like just be early
human communities you know gathering
around a fire as like a parent or a
grandparent or some Community Elder you
know tells the story and for that 30
minutes or 45 minutes or whatever
everyone is just sort of
imaginatively transported away you know
they've kind of left their mundane lives
and there they are like in the
imagination just gone you know in a
different world or whatever and so right
it's there's entertainment there or they
played games and they right every of
course this is like it's fine you know
so so it's the point isn't like oh fun
is bad never have fun or don't do
anything enjoyable Jesus doesn't want
you to do that um it's it's uh it's more
that well there's just maybe one way to
summ it up is to say there's just a
difference between a
culture um with entertainment and an
entertainment
culture what I mean by that is uh it's
like entertainment it's become so
pervasive that it's sort of like you
work so that you can
amuse yourself with 10,000 kind of
distractions and things and it just sort
of endless right so it's it's kind of
about quantity and as we'll see it's a
little bit too of how we use these
things like um some of it though is
quantity like I'm thinking of you know
again every culture had its Slice of
Life where it's like yeah it's it's have
some fun you know have to be entertained
uh now I I'll do a a specific sermon on
on like digital distraction and such but
I'll just name like for example the kind
of power of like Instagram and Tik Tok
and the way you can kind of slip into
this mode like have you noticed this
happening where you never have like any
kind of moment where you're not kind of
almost compulsively sort of reaching for
the phone like just to be inter pain to
distract yourself to engage something
you know I mean you just kind of need
stimulus need stimul like just need to
do something like all the time you know
whether it's you're standing in line and
you can't just stand in line you know
what I mean just I gotta do something
what about a video oh it's hilar you
know I mean like or I found myself at um
the like like pumping
gas and it's it's so hard for me to just
like well just watching the meter you
know I mean just kind of watching the
numbers go up uh and like no I kind of
need to reach RM like I we this is a the
three minutes where I could be
entertained you know what I mean or even
if I I avoid my phone at least they've
kind of started to go away from this in
recent years I think maybe people were
annoyed but like did you go to those gas
stations where they had the little
screen feeding you these cartoonish
little commercials and they're like buy
a slurpie by a slurpie you know what I
mean and it's sort of like oh good at
least there's something to watch you
know just kind of tuned in um this is
like that's the thing with the culture
where it just kind of slips in it's just
always sort
of you know I mean just go going going
going going go go hey heyy you know I
mean it's just constant stimulus noise
going entertainment just kind of in like
that's that's where the
problem
comes uh and that that's the difference
between kind of a culture with
entertainment and like an an
entertainment culture that's kind of
rooted and grounded in this I mean I'm
thinking probably previous generations
at least would have said that our life
in world and culture is what they would
have wanted although now that we're here
I don't know if it's really what we need
you know or if maybe they might look
kind of like oh maybe this isn't for the
best you know I mean like I'm imagining
I have it on good authority that
previous generations were so starved for
entertainment they would go to the
airport to watch people's planes take
off yall heard of this I think my I
think my parents did this I don't know
maybe some of you have done this like
where it's you're like you know I mean
you're kind of you love that's that's
beauti I'm not nothing against it I'm
just saying there's um now about 1,000
things that people you know options in
other words we got options and some
might say too many options you know I
mean where it's just sort of this
constant um thing right there's just
this different difference between a
culture with entertainment and an
entertainment
culture um Neil postman has written
really um in depth on this he wrote a
wonderful book it's a great title
amusing ourselves to death uh and he
wrote this back in like the was maybe
the 90s I think maybe even 80s uh but he
was seeing this kind of Rise of you know
this these shifts in culture and such
and uh he he kind of charted
how there's there was certain kind of
aspects of culture that had always been
kind of I don't know uh partitioned off
a bit from entertainment you know in
other words you had your entertainment
things but then you had other aspects of
culture that weren't like the purpose
wasn't to be entertained and this is
what Postman saw was how it's like in an
entertainment
culture uh it's it's kind of erased like
if you don't grab people's
attention you're
ignored and so what happens
Everything feels the need to become
entertaining everything even things that
maybe it's not so good like for example
um
education right becomes whereas there's
a day where it's sort of like
education's about becoming educated you
know I mean but now there's in an
entertainment culture it's like well how
are we gonna make this into you know I
mean kind of a way it's fun to learn
math you know I mean like you gotta you
kind of gotta try to keep everyone going
because that's the can you see where
this kind of happens um so it can happen
in um entertainment it can happen with
um
politics right just think of uh I
mentioned this in a sermon a few years
ago how like Abraham Lincoln way back in
the day like they would publish his
whole speech in like a newspaper and
that was how you you know people became
informed about who am i g to vote for
let me read their speeches you know
there were like thousands and thousands
of words and I just imagining like when
was the last time you read like a
presidential you know what I mean like a
long or even if you
could would it be worth it you know what
I mean why
because today that well politics is
reality
television It's Entertainment right how
do you get elected it's it's capture
people's
attention and and so suddenly you've got
education you got politics you got
journalism of course this happens um the
Arts right feel the need to become
entertain or else they can't you no
one's paying attention um and then
finally of course religion I mean just
think for a moment how have churches
shifted in the last say 50 years in
response to entertainment
culture that's like it's a little I mean
as a pastor I'll just say that's a
chilling
question
um we even recently actually we're
taking the month of June we're doing a
little experiment where um from 4:15 to
4:45 each Sunday um in the cross room
the the classroom with many many crosses
in uh down here in the hallway we're
just taking some space for silence and
so anyone that wants to and you can do
that any any Sunday in June will'll be
in there 4:15 to 4:45 and we're just you
know what what are we doing just
sitting quietly you know you can pray
you or not or just
sit right that's that's something of a
response to where you can just see
Christian faith has gone where it's sort
of like it just becomes who can have the
best show in
town ew you know like it just at some
point you gain the whole world and you
lose your soul it just what are we even
doing right th this is
it's a tremendous problem the uh David
Foster Wallace the the writer um also
wrote super eloquently on this you can
find some YouTube videos as well with
him interviews with him um talking on
this this topic and I found this um well
he was asking someone asked him how do
you combat this kind of entertainment
culture you know and he said uh well
it's really difficult this is the quote
he said um if uh if fighting against
entertainment is even required how does
one do it unless well there are two
options one is you direct you direct the
attack only to people who are willing to
listen to the complexity but those
aren't the people who are enslaved by
entertainment
anyway or you find some way to make the
attack on
entertainment
entertaining in which case you've been
captured by the very thing you're
fighting against that that sums it up
like like that's the the problem Lord
have mercy so what are we to do I I
think some of it is we've got to sort of
discern how we're using entertainment
again not to demonize or not to say we
should never be entertained but to to
kind of discern what's going on here
what is the kind of maybe unhealthy
aspect um of this again David Foster
Wallace he said part of the Ure of drugs
and entertainment is
escape yes
I love that he pairs these
two part of the Allure is of drugs and
entertainment is
escape because I think obviously we know
like well you know be careful with drugs
or whatever you know like but
entertainment oh that's fine no worries
you know but so that's and I think
that's some of what we have to kind of
discern is how is this kind of constant
need for stimulus entertainment how am I
starting to use it as a form of escape
and you say Escape From what I think
that's the that's kind of the trick
isn't it
um from almost
everything in essence we start to try to
kind of escape from our
lives sometimes it's just like things we
need to do you know or or some a lot of
times it's uh it's escape from
ourselves isn't it escape from like our
feelings in
thoughts uh emotions memories
traumas it's like I just can't handle me
you know and I just I want to get
out but that's the kind of dangerous
thing just like with drugs where it's
like well I just need like a little
break you know what I mean just one out
for just a little while but then I just
keep wanting to be to escape more and
more and more until Suddenly It's like
what happened to my life and I think
that's the the kind of pernicious thing
here um is that to come out of
entertainment culture in essence it's
it's almost like it's the art of
learning to live
again let me say it again to to come out
of entertainment culture is the art of
learning to live again this is where I
think people have very confused IDE
ideas about religion and
Christianity um they they think it's all
about like going to heaven after you die
or something you know uh Christian
spirituality isn't about teaching us how
to live in heaven after we die but about
how to live here on Earth with our feet
planted firmly upon the Earth and our
minds dwelling deeply in the here in the
now like that's the
invitation and so what I want to do
tonight is I want to invite you back to
your
life back to your
world back to
yourself back to the people you
love back to God
because it's like when we engage this
entertainment culture we're just
gone we're just gone sometimes hours
slip by just
gone we might say that the way out is
through right drugs drinking to excess
binge watching TV you know etc etc it's
all it's an out but it's temporary you
know it's an Escape but that's the
problem is is the high always ends the
distraction always runs its course and
then you know I'm just back to me you're
just back to you and your feelings and
your life but there comes a day when you
say you know
what no
more no more I I want to come home I
want to
return I want to come home to my life
and my family in my world I'm ready to
exit the kingdom of noise and pleasure
and endless entertainment as I
desperately numb out I'm ready to come
home to
return a really helpful word I found in
all this is the word
awareness
awareness the Buddhists would call it
mindfulness the desert fathers and
mothers would call it
attentiveness or watchfulness
this was their primary spiritual
practice like I think we often think of
practice as like you know almost like a
thing we need to do or something special
or unique I think probably the most
basic and
foundational spiritual practice and and
like something I found essential to
following Christ is simply to be
here you know that's almost step
one gotta be where you are
because I mean how can you do anything
else how can you know mean how can you
build out from there if you're like no
home you know what I mean so that that's
Step One is this awareness it's this
constant return this this coming back to
ourselves in fact take a moment and
simply be
aware it's good that we have the rain
so just take a moment just just kind of
tune into this room the space the people
around
you just be present
be present to this space without thought
analysis or
judgment simply in the Silence of your
mind be
aware come
home here's a few quotes from the desert
father St hesek
us and every time he mentions
attentiveness or watchfulness just think
awareness he wrote attentiveness is the
heart's Stillness Unbroken by any
thought in this Stillness the heart
breathes and invokes endlessly and
without ceasing only Jesus Christ who is
the Son of God and is himself God when
he's speaking here of the heart he
doesn't mean literally the you know the
organ in your chest think um
like deep mind that that part of your
mind that is aware but isn't necessarily
the uh Chatterbox in your brain that's
you know chatting you up all the
time he also wrote watchfulness is a
continual fixing and halting of thought
at the entrance to the
heart he says Be watchful as you travel
each day the narrow but joyous and
exhilarating Road of the Mind humbly in
your
heart another way he puts it is to talk
about the opposite
forgetfulness which of course is what
happens when we engage in a lot of
entertainment he said we should shun
loose speech like an asps Venom and too
much company like a progyny of Vipers
for can plunge us into total
forgetfulness of the inner struggle and
bring the soul down from the heights of
the joy that purity of heart gives
this accursed forgetfulness is as
opposed to attentiveness as water to
Fire and forcibly fights against it all
the
time forgetfulness leads to negligence
and negligence to indifference laziness
and unnatural desire in this way we
return to where we started like a dog to
his own
vomit you see I don't know about you but
I know this forgetfulness well you ever
been someplace and it's like you sudden
maybe this happens all the time when
you're driving you're like how did I get
here or you're walking how did I get
here or you're standing with the fridge
open how did I get
here
forgetfulness default
mode and so this is what we have to do
is come awake again
as the psalmist writes one thing I have
asked from the Lord in this or that I
shall seek that I may dwell in the house
of the Lord all the days of my life to
behold the beauty of the Lord and to
meditate in his
Temple see I believe that we can do that
all the time and we don't have to
Journey to the temple in
Jerusalem and we don't have to travel
and like come into the church Sanctuary
you know every day or something um but
we can
[Music]
behold one another we can
Behold our life our world I love that
word behold it's used over 1700 times in
the Bible it's a contemplative word you
know it doesn't just mean look look at
that thing you know but it's to behold
it it's like to to be aware awake to
it when I am holding I'm not worried or
stressed or afraid or uneasy or
ruminating endlessly I am deeply
present and I believe that's the shift
that we need so friends I want to invite
you back to your life back to good food
and people and a walk in the woods in a
good book or the Silence of church or
prayer I want to invite you into this
holy shift from entertainment to
awareness back to the sacred life God
has given you in the name of the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so as we come to the table of the
Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
in the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine may we do it with
awareness may we be present to ourselves
to God to one another as we come forward
may we do it wide
awake so the way we'll partake is um
we're going to just go row by row here
just starting at the front and kind of
working our way back and we'll form a
line right here um we practice what's
called an Open Table meaning if you're
here tonight and you want to participate
that you are free to do that um having
said that there's no pressure If you'd
rather not participate that's perfectly
fine too um you should know the red is
wine the white is grape juice deep they
Warn and finally you can just partake
whenever you'd like so no one will lead
you through the exact moment some folks
like to come and kneel uh some people
take immediately others return to their
seats however however you'd like to
partake we welcome you that so this is
the table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come you who have much
faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to
follow and you have
failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet and here come to the table
[Music]
in
thank you guys for serving us communion
tonight I appreciate you ladies um and I
just want to invite the rest of you to
stay seated during this last song if
you'd like to um just the words of this
last song felt so relevant because I
feel like so often some of the
entertainment at least for me that I'm
looking for is sometimes to escape the
negative or the the scary thoughts the
lack of control the
fear um guilt or shame that I need to
face you know um and the words of this
chorus I just feel like are so powerful
as we try to be more present more
attentive more thoughtfulness and aware
um so you guys just receive this message
and as Hank and Eden set out on this
next season I pray that these words in
this course will ring out in your hearts
and that you will remember this with
every step that you
[Music]
take you've owned your fear and all your
self lothing you've owned the voices
inside of your head you've on the shame
and reproach of your
fa it's time to your
belov you've owned your past and how
it's defined you you've owned everything
everybody else say it's time to hear
with your father father has
spoken it's time to own your
[Music]
belovedness and he says your mind smiled
when I made you I find you beautiful in
every way my love for you is fierce and
ending I'll come to find you whatever it
takes
my
belov you on the M you see in the mirror
you've R the lies that you're just not
enough you've been so blinded by all
you're
comparing it's time to own your Bel
[Music]
love and he says you
smiled when I made you I find you
beautiful in every
way my love for you is fierce and an
ending how come to find you whatever it
takes my
belov you are
[Music]
completely loved and fully
know beloved
believe he died to make your AR his home
he says your mind smiled when I made you
I find you beautiful in every
way my love for you is fierce and
unending
I'll come to find you whatever it takes
he says your mind smil when I made you I
find you beautiful in every way my love
for you is fierce and
unending I'll come to find you whatever
is my
my
Bel
[Music]
my it's time to your
belovedness thank you so much for being
here I'm so happy to see all of you um
if you're new we'd love for you to fill
out and scan the QR code um on the
screens or there's some on the table on
the way out um just so we could follow
up with you answer any questions you
might have um and just thank you for
being here if you are in need of a
prayer or a hug or you just need
somebody to talk to um I'll be here um I
would love to be here for you however I
can I'll just be standing over there
after the service
um here at the table we are committed to
creating an inclusive Christ centered
community that touches lives and
generosity is a key component to doing
that work um if you'd like to join us in
supporting this work financially you can
also scan that QR code or you can visit
uh the table tx.org don't forget about
the potluck that's happening right after
a service tonight in the Family Life
Center right across the way um so we can
hope that you'll eat and celebrate
senior Sunday with us um so now I'm
going to uh send you into your week with
a blessing you can either hold your
hands out or open your heart uh to
receive these
words you are a child of God you are a
child of God this is true on your best
day and this is true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
into contact with and Lord would you
bless our food as We Gather tonight to
celebrate senior Sunday pride month and
this wonderful Community amen
[Music]
and he says your mind smil when made you
I find You Beautiful in
everywhere my love for you is fierce and
unending I'll come to find you whatever
it my
belove it's time to on you
[Music]
belovedness you